[Music]
hello and welcome back to the endgame
class
uh as always my name is caleb denby and
today i want to be taking you through
some critical end games that have helped
to determine
the next challenger for magnus carlsen
in the world championship
of course these are end games from the
first half of the candidates tournament
this year in 2020 i'm not sure when the
players are set to play the second half
just yet of course it's still
all up in the air the last i heard uh
but these uh end games in the first half
are definitely going to be crucial so
let's
take a look first and foremost at a
position between
the chinese player wang hao and the
frenchman
maxime vashilograv so in
this position wang hao was playing with
the white pieces
and ended up with a pretty incredibly
interesting
end game so here black chose to play
the move king g8 bringing the king
back towards the center and wong hao
made a very interesting decision now to
play the move d5
which allows black to trade the queens
oops
i've skipped the end ruining everything
ruining everything
i'm the worst which allowed black to
play the move
okay so kng8 d5 allowed black to play
the move queen takes c3
knight takes c3 and now knight a5
uh bishop d3 removing the uh the bishop
from the throat of capture
and after e takes d5 e takes d5 we have
sort of arrived at the end game i wanted
to
talk about today so what do you guys in
the chat
think is going on in this endgame would
you rather be white here
or black and why and then we'll
talk a little bit about it what do you
guys think
as you filter in here
what is going on here manny wants to be
white
david says black has two connected pawns
but the d-pawn looks dangerous so
you guys are arriving at the heart of
the subject
of course the main imbalance to look at
here
is this pawn on d5 versus black's pawn
on d6 of course the remaining pawns are
sort of symmetrical
so the question is would you rather have
this past pawn all the way on d5
or this more solid looking pawn back
here on b6
and in this case definitely it's going
to be white
who is preferred in this position the
reason for that
is this d-pawn is yes
passed and threatening to step forward
and try to promote sort of at any moment
but also it's not really going to be too
weak on the d5 square the reason for
that
is the white king is very ready to step
to d4
it can't really be driven off of the d4
square
and from d4 it will sort of permanently
defend
this pawn on d5 meanwhile
black can add his own king as an
attacker but this knight is nowhere
close to being able to attack this
d-pawn
in fact black is going to have to work
pretty hard to solve this issue of the
knight on
a5 which is sort of reason number two to
prefer white
in this position reason number three
is for those of you with a tactical mind
you may have realized that this guy is
not so
easy to defend due to the misplacement
of black's knight
on a5 and in fact there is simply no way
for black
to maintain control of the a7 pawn in
this position
uh how is that true
well white would love to play for
example after king f8
the move knight b5 and take this guy
unfortunately for white
right now the d pawn does hang but of
course white can play king e3
and king d4 and now there's nothing to
stop white
from going knight b5 and capturing on a7
so we have the move bishop c8 on the
board black
needed to get this knight back into play
knight b5
and now a6 tries to hold on to the pond
hold on to the pawn but you may have
realized knight c7 now
adds two attackers to this guy at first
glance you might think you can play the
move
b5 but now king c5 and king b6
is going to be difficult to stop white
is winning this pawn
one way or another so in the game
after knight c7 black simply chose king
d6
and now we have the move knight takes a6
and we have arrived at the main position
of the next 40 moves this
is sort of what we have to look at here
so the move
knight b7 was played in the game
uh retreating this knight back to
uh b7 preparing to bring it out to a
more active square
like c5 or d6 and now i think
white's next move may have been the move
to determine the result of this game so
let's
really stop and think in this position
i'm going to ask you guys to spend
probably a little bit more time than i
normally ask you to spend here
try and find white's best move in the
position
and if you are someone
who tends to solve these answers using a
chess engine
it may not be able to help you here
because chess engines
while they normally arrive at the win
eventually they don't always understand
what is the best practical move for
uh an attacking player to try to make in
order to win
win the end game whereas
white's best move in this position i
think is number one very human
and number two uh sort of the simplest
way to go about it so
really stop here and consider
your next option with the white pieces
stop and consider here
chess king says he likes
f5 so he says g4 he says g4 g5 is his
idea
manny says bishop b5
so try and provide some sort of
reasoning
behind the moves here
try and think long term as well try and
think long term
so yeah try and provide some reasoning
with the moves because
i do think this is sort of the time to
plan out your your next your next
however many moves your next idea
to try to make progress this is the time
to plan it out
so if you provide one move that's not an
idea to make progress you have to
understand
that your move has to have an idea to
progress the position forward to
be closer to winning the end game
so mateo says knight b8 to play knight
c6
sure but what is your idea to make
progress
how does knight c8 allow you to make
progress how does white make progress in
this endgame
and then how do you actually achieve
that with chess moves
end games are very very concrete things
so a lot of you guys in the chat have
some like repositioning ideas like
you're saying hey wouldn't this knife be
great on c6 compared to a6 and
and maybe that's true but it doesn't
have a concrete idea
you need some concrete idea to make
progress
how does white make progress he doesn't
make progress
by putting a knight on c6 not on c6
looks good
but it's not progress
so krish has the first idea that i've
seen
so far that actually is an attempt to
make progress
krish wants to play knight b4 knight c2
knight e3 and knight c4 with check
why is this an idea to make progress
because
it's not just repositioning the knight
it's repositioning the knight with the
purpose
of pushing the white pawn forward
so why is this an idea to make progress
what is white hoping to achieve
after knight c4
okay and then matteo has an idea we'll
look at matteo's idea in a second but
let's
let's start with this nice c4 idea how
does white continue to make progress
after after the move knight c4 what does
white have to do
king e5 so krish has the right plan here
so we would love to play knight b4 then
i'm just going to pass
with black for now
and eventually play knight c4 check
king c7 for example and king e5
and how is this making progress for
white well it's making progress
because now white is going to be able to
come through and win these pawns
or even more directly come through
and uh win some stuff over on this side
of the board
as as well
sort of devastating right so we have an
idea to make progress
with white however when you want to
analyze
an endgame you yes have to come up with
your concrete idea
but a lot of the time it's going to be
much more useful for you
if you can try and find some way that
your opponent
can stop you so is black powerless
can black do nothing against the idea of
knight b4 to c2 to e3 to c4 check
followed by king e5
or in those four moves that he has is
there some way for black
to make life a little bit more difficult
for white
is there any way black can put up some
resistance there so sort of the next
thing you have to look at
uh and while you're thinking about that
let's look at this so matteo was saying
knight b8
and he wants to go after these pawns so
immediately
off the bat it looks like the issue is
going to be
let's say black passes or something well
okay this is a bit better than passing
let's say
yeah i don't know tough to pass the
point is even if you get to e8
king e7 is rejecting this bishop
right uh knight d8 also defends the f7
square
so this idea not going to be
the best so back to your initial
question
what is stopping white from just easily
winning the game
knight b4 c2 e3 c4 king e5 king f6 to
follow d6 to follow
game over what is stopping this from
happening
so there's some ideas in the chat some
ideas in the chat
one idea is for black to play knight c5
and bishop a6 that's being suggested
another idea is knight a5
to sort of just very very directly
control the c4 square and so let's talk
about that a little bit
because what's at the core of white's
idea here the core of white's idea
is not necessarily knight c4 check it's
to remove the king
from the d6 square and so these sort of
artificial looking ways of stopping it
for black something like knight a5
really aren't going to work in the long
run so let's say
black just plants this knight on a5
and passes right 93
pass right it's true that you've stopped
knight c4
however what you haven't done is stop
white's idea entirely right
for example here um
let me find sort of the best path to uh
to get there
something like knight d1 let's say pass
knight f2 and knight e4 check right
we're still sort of a sort of getting
getting to our point somehow if you try
something like
f5 well i'm not so sure this
is ideal for you to put the pawns on
on these squares but we're going to talk
about that a little bit more in depth
uh later on the point is knight a5 not
enough
to to stop it you do need things some
something like f5 to follow as well
right so what else what else can black
do
you guys were mentioning knight c5 uh
let's say
white chooses to save this bishop
or actually maybe just chooses to go
knight c2 anyways okay well then this is
a problem i guess
so let's say white chooses to save this
bishop
let's just do it simply with the move
bishop e5
let's say bishop b7 challenging the pawn
i'm kind of confusing myself here
somehow
so apologies let me take just a second
uh yeah and this this might be a little
bit of a better way
of preventing this idea let's say though
instead i try a little bit harder
play the move bishop c4 challenge or
defending the d5 pawn now
bishop b7 still allows this knight to be
a bit mobile
still have ideas of knight c2 here let's
say knight back to a6
knight out to e3 knight back to c5
and one way or another we're getting rid
of this king
one way or another we're going to find
them and we're going to get them get
them get them all right
so the idea that you guys have not
mentioned yet
is the idea of defending the e5 square
there are sort of these tactical ideas
to make removing the king from d6
difficult for white
but you sort of get the feeling that
given enough time white is going to be
able to organize his pieces in such a
way
that he can challenge this king on d6
right these sort of artificial looking
ways
of trying to stop it by you know
pressuring this pawn a little bit
or by just defending the square they may
work in the short term
but given enough time white may be able
to maneuver his
way around to a square like e4 or c4 or
b5 with the knight
to remove the black king however there
is
sort of a better solution here for black
to try and draw the game and that
solution is to put this pawn on g5
and put this pawn on f6 and the point
now
is that if knight e3 bishop d7
knight c4 check king c7
king e5 has been prevented and this is
sort of the fortress-like position
that black might be able to achieve
so if you thought of this idea for black
kudos to you
because this is a really uh fantastic
try
at creating a fortress-like position for
black
now something like knight to e3 this
knight can step to d6
and it's going to be very difficult to
break through
anywhere on the board for white after
this setup has sort of been achieved in
fact i would go as far as to say
i might think this position is sort of
just
dead drawn if black achieves this setup
with g5
and f6 so let this be sort of a lesson
yes for you as the attacking side to
look for these types of setups for your
opponent
but also as the defending side always be
on the lookout for these sort of
opportunities
to try and permanently uh sort of
nullify the game
because if you try these less permanent
ways of preventing
your opponent's ideas stuff like knight
c5 and bishop b7 or knight a5
that we were talking about you sort of
are always going to have to be on the
back foot
always being ready to meet white's next
threat with some new temporary solution
and at the end of the day more often
than not
those games end up being won by the
attacking side
the reason being eventually there's just
a threat that black is not ready to
tactically meet
whereas if black achieves something like
this black no longer
has to try black just literally
does this
and and how does how does white break
through i'm not so sure
that he can so now
we have arrived at the point
of stopping at this turn we have found
a winning idea for white it's knight b4
knight c2 knight e3 knight c4 and we
have found a drawing technique for black
going g5 and f6 and i do want to mention
somewhere along the line maybe
white has some tactical winds something
like bishop a6 here
so black might have to be a bit more
cautious something like knight c5
first knight c2 well sorry we might have
to deal with this so bishop c4
and now let's say the immediate
uh f6 g5 for example this is probably
a tactically sound way of achieving the
same idea
for uh for black even g5 first followed
by
followed by this move f6 so this this
would be a more tactically sound the
first line i showed i think bishop a6
might have been winning
but knight c5 first followed by this uh
fortress idea would be good enough for
black so
back to this position with all of that
in mind
how do you win with white white to move
and find
a winning idea here
and yeah manny has a great idea
it's to play the move f4 and i think
this is practically
the absolute best that uh best move
that white can play i think this move in
the long run
ends up to ends up being winning because
it's preventing this tactical idea
for black to play the move g5 and sort
of
end the game uh mateo has a question
first though about bishop d7 here
and i think i don't fully understand why
why matteo wants to to pause here
it would be a very similar idea for for
white going for this
and black would still have to go for
this g5 f6 idea
oh and i think i do remember i'm saying
something about playing the move b5
so the problem with playing b5 is that
the second you put that pawn there
you have another weakness that you have
to defend right on b6 the pawn is
relatively safe can be defended by the
king
on b5 that's not the case right this
pawn
is sort of falling or knight c4 check is
is coming even faster
but okay let's talk about uh the move f4
right so with f4 white is
locking down the g5 square and making
this plan
of blacks to play f6 and g5 much more
difficult
to achieve
now for example let's talk about some
drawing ideas
for black if he tries to fix the pawns
like this
well now the issue is going to be that
white once again is going to be going
for
the plan of playing some type of check
to this king
using the knight removing it from the d6
square
and then playing king e5 and this once
again is going to be very very difficult
to stop for example bishop b7
something like knight c2 and
black might pass knight a3 knight f6
knight b5 check king d7
and this type of stuff is going to be
difficult to stop
for the moment black tactically has this
threat solved with something like knight
g4
but is that going to be a permanent uh
fix i'm not so sure white also has ideas
of playing d6 with bishop f7 to follow
and well i don't tactically see the wind
immediately
for white here after g3 he still does
always have these ideas
of making progress in this manner
perhaps
actually i do see a pretty good idea for
him
maybe we can reroute
in in this manner sort of knight b5
check
bishop f3 and then this to follow with
this threat being taken care of
would be strong okay
so f5 doesn't quite do it the reason
being king e5
has not been prevented um other drawing
ideas
for black let's say he tries to play the
move knight c5
taking advantage of this bishop well
then i think the move
knight takes c5 would be good enough but
we don't even need this trick because i
think knight before
knight takes d3 knight takes d3 would
also be
pretty convincing here for white
bishop b7 is sort of the only try to
challenge this guy
knight b4 to defend and
now i think the issue is going to be
uh bishop a8 king b5
and you just can't hold everything
together here with the black pieces
knight a6 check to follow and this guy
falls
um so i do think that f4
is just a technically winning move here
once again if bishop d7 knight b4 knight
c5
bishop c4 is going to be similar to
things that we've just looked at
and even the move bishop e2 is going to
be a perfectly playable idea
with the point being something like g4
and g5 to follow
with an extra weakness now on the king's
side for black
so with all of that in mind f4 i'm
claiming
is the winning idea here for white
preventing this perfect defensive setup
for black
with g5 and f6 so does anybody have any
questions
about this idea of f4 does anybody think
it's not good enough to win
uh obviously it's still going to be a
complex end game after
f4 but i do believe this is white's best
shot
at a win and from what i can tell it
should
be winning every line i've analyzed
deeply
has always resulted in some way to break
through for
white so any questions
about this
so then the question is
everybody seems to agree uh what should
black do
after white plays g4 this was wong hao's
choice in the game
so what should black do here
what should black do here
and yeah you guys all have the answer of
course black should play the move g5
and in fact this is exactly what
happened in the game wong hao went with
g4
mvl went with g5 and now i do
actually think that this is a
technically drawn end game i do not
see how black is going to be
busted here i don't see how white is
going to break through
in the game wong hao tried knight b4
bishop d7
knight c2 king a7 knight e3
with an idea you guys may recognize of
course trying to
take control of d6 but now after knight
d6
king e5 is meaningless because of f6
check
knight d1 was played bishop a4
knight f2 f6 and black has
achieved his desired fortress the
players played on
for many many many many many turns but
black now was happy with repetitions
until he found this opportunity to play
knight c7
and sort of take over by challenging
this d5 pawn
bishop e3 king d6 more checks
and the game was eventually drawn and in
fact it was actually black
who decided to shake things up first
playing this move
f5 uh before white got the chance to
even
even try anything g f bishop takes
knight takes knight takes king e4
knight h4 and this position is
just a draw
with black just passing the time
just passing the time
notably if white ever tries king f5 this
is sort of the only thing you can try
then king takes d5 and
the game was agreed to a draw
so there are a few points i want to get
across with this end game that hopefully
you guys
are able to sort of internalize
number one this idea of
not thinking about specific moves in
these end games
don't think about move by move by move
think about a way to make progress
find some some idea some way to make
progress in the game and focus on that
don't focus on
you know just some general idea of
improving the pieces putting them on
better squares
focus on a way to make tangible progress
and that's how you're going to find
the winning plans if you try stuff like
knight b8
and sort of just shuffle around trying
to improve the pieces somehow
you know maybe here maybe a three for
some reason
you're not gonna not gonna make progress
you need a tangible idea that's the
first
and foremost thing i hope you guys uh
can can get from this okay secondly
this idea of the defending side sort of
slowing down that idea of making
progress the defensive side
should also be trying to find ways for
the opponent to try to make progress
and doing their best to solve those
problems before they actually arrive
in this case g5 and f6
and thirdly you can go even deeper and
with the attacking side
looking at potential setups for your
opponent like g5 and f6
and trying to play against them that's
how you can arrive at
really key moves like f4 in this
position
that's how you can discover these types
of ideas so
any and get or any questions on this end
game now before we move on
if after f4 black plays bishop f5
uh i think we could just capture this
guy i think this is going to be good
enough
this guy is sort of indefensible right
the king can't come to e6
and i think it's just as simple as
simple as
as attacking this pawn knight g3
but now you're not in time to stop king
e5
king e7 means this king c7
means this and we didn't quite have time
to play
f6 to stop knight c4 check
[Music]
could black put his knight on d6 and his
bishop on e7 as
a defense d7 he means after f4
let's take a look let's say bishop d7
and white continues with this idea
king c7 i guess well now this would give
up king e5
so yeah i guess the issue is going to be
that um
king e5 is always going to be too too
strong right
going to be too strong here
does that make sense and if you tried a
little bit later let's say knight c5
knight e3 king e7
well yeah let's even give black a move
here to play
knight d6 i think knight c4 is going to
be good enough to win
uh well actually maybe not because of
knight takes c4 i think g4 g5
is likely going to be good enough and
king e5 is still going to be
sort of this this devastating threat
right uh
so not only tactically does it work out
but i think even if you achieve this
uh i don't think it's going to be going
to be good enough
for black here uh
yeah pretty sure pretty sure g4 is going
to be good enough
if you go back to these ideas of f5
still you're running into problems over
here and problems of
of king e5 threats maybe not immediately
but
king e5 threats this is also coming as
well
difficult position difficult position
okay how many moves was this game
uh the actual game continuation took 83
moves this position that we're looking
at to start with here
was move 30 36 but many of those moves
were after black had achieved the
defensive setup and white was sort of
trying and trying and trying
but not getting anywhere as we've seen
let
us now move on to a game between
uh uh korril uh alexeyenko
who was i believe the russian pick for
the wild card
this candidates against everybody's
favorite
uh player anish geary who doesn't love a
good old-fashioned
anish giri game
so let's take a look here the starting
position i want to look at
is this one after the move queen f6
we have on our hands a very complex end
game
that involve the queens and the knights
the first question i want to ask is who
should be
better in this end game and this one is
probably
going to be a little bit more intuitive
than the last one
the last one is you know not
counter-intuitive but you could kind of
see how the d-pawn might be a weakness
in this case of course it is just white
with all of
the weaknesses here the d pawn is weak
the b
pawns are weak and white does not have
enough activity to make up for it so yes
black is going to be better in this case
uh so let's see what happens in the game
for the next few turns
and then we'll slow down and think about
it so for the moment black is making a
threat
white plays the move queen e4 to defend
it we have
g6 by black it's always a good idea to
play against the knight in these kinds
of positions
also making left for the king we have
knight e2
and now we have the move knight e6
and now white comes up with a pretty
interesting
idea to try and pressure the black king
a little bit
he goes with the move h4 and
perhaps with some ideas of playing h5
and even h6 a little bit later on
to like i said pressure in the black
king but
black's having none of it he plays the
move h5 and white plays the move g3
and i wanted to include these moves
because
i think this is a really uh instructive
structure that both players have created
here
i was actually talking to a friend of
mine who was playing a rapid game
just online and he had some you know
decisions to make about which pawn
structure to go for on the king's side
well the end game play kind of continued
on the queen side of the board
and that's a situation that i think
players run into a lot
they have three versus three on the
king's side some other situation
on the queen side of the board where
play is a little bit more interesting
this is sort of where the game's going
to be decided
but first both players sort of have to
decide what they want their king side
pawns to look like
before they can get to the meat of the
game over here on the queen side
and this structure f7 g6 h5
is a structure i see high level grand
masters going for
all the time in these end games and i
think the reason for that
is this is a very very stable structure
for both sides f7 g6 h5
the reason for that is of course you
never get backrank mated
the king in fact has options here if it
turns out the diagonal
is an issue the king can step to h7 if
it turns out the seventh rank is an
issue the king can step to g7
and can always shift between the two he
has an escape route
out through h6 if things get too crazy
in this case of course it is blocked by
the h pawn for white as well
but in some cases this is important
these pawns all defend each other
there's nothing to worry about there
the f7 pawn defends against uh threats
from the seventh rank the g6 pawn from
this diagonal
as i've stated before and
it's sort of resilient against attacks
by enemy pawns you know it's not so easy
to break down this structure and if you
try
this structure can easily be changed
into a structure that is not
so bad either for example f3 g4
might be an attempt to change the
structure but black is usually happy to
play h takes g
in those situations and then f7 g6
is almost as good as f7 g6 h5 so
i wanted to highlight that both players
consciously chose
to create this structure in this end
game because i really do believe
this is sort of the best you can do on
the king site
in most cases most cases of course there
are exceptions
but in most cases this is the best you
can do
all right with that in mind let's move
on with the end game
we have queen to d8
yet don't know what the issues uh that
you guys are talking about in the chat
uh but hopefully it gets resolved uh so
queen v8 played in the game
and the idea here now is like i said
black
has uh created his structure on the
king's side
and now he can start to look for play on
the queen side as well
queen d8 just rerouting this queen
uh queen e5 was white's choice but now
queen
b6 and like i said uh going for play
on the clean side in the meantime of
course we see the power
of black's pawn structure queen p8 check
does nothing
because at the end of the day while this
looks like perpetual
black has given himself this extra
option of coming to h7
in this case the seventh rank doesn't
matter the diagonal matters so black can
choose h7
just wanted to highlight that one more
time okay
so black of course is challenging these
two pawns
white needs to do something to uh sort
of prevent it
and so white comes up with this tactical
idea of playing the move d5
uh we have c takes d5 on the board if
queen takes b3 we're to be played
sorry excuse me this hang's a knight so
you can't do that of course
so cd5 played queen d5 and now king f8
and we have these two sort of fractured
pawns for white
against these two slightly healthier
pawns for plaque
and for that reason i still would
actually prefer
black in this position that being said i
do think
after those slight complications this
position
should more or less be drawn however
we'll see
that despite his reputation anish geary
is actually a very very talented player
at pushing these very slight advantages
uh even if technically the game is
you know equal drawn there are practical
chances here
for black and anish geary is actually a
very talented player
at playing these positions for a win
you know sort of getting everything he
can out of them why king f8
i'm going to be honest with you here
king f8 is a little
a little bit mysterious even a little
mis
a little bit mysterious even to me it's
the type of position
where rapid changes aren't really going
to be happening
and king f8 i think is just a move
marking time
it's worth noting that the players are
on move 34 in the game
and i do believe they got extra time at
mu 40
so moves like king f8 are sort of
non-committal but they're not really
going to be changing the evaluation of
the position
and you'll see players do that when they
do have this extra time
at move 40. uh knight c3 was played
queen c7 knight into e4 white is just
sort of activating his knight now
creating some threats around the king
queen c1 check
and queen takes b2 uh so
we do actually end up finding uh white
going down a pawn here which i sort of
glossed over because i
forgot it happened so quickly i thought
they did this after move 40 but no
knight e4 was in fact upon sacrifice
and the reason alexianco does this is
because he thought he could go
for some mating attacks against the
black king and perhaps this is also why
black brought this king to f8 i should
mention
stepping out of potential knight f6
checks as
well interesting stuff now
was white forced to go for this
no white was not really forced to to go
in for this
at all white could have very easily
played something like king f1
knight a4 they could have played this
position out for hours and hours and
hours
without anybody actually making any
progress here
instead though knight e4 alex sango
wants to solve all of the issues
immediately
get out this black king get some kind of
perpetual check or mating attack
and in exchange all he has to give up is
this little
b2 pawn so queen c1 check queen takes b2
and now queen d7 is blacks or whites try
to to end the game
notably white can take on b7 here
but black would play the move queen d4
and to be honest with you this one is
likely going to be
a draw as well maybe alexayenko didn't
want to go for this
because for the moment this knight is
actually a little bit trapped
knight g5 isn't going to be ideal
creating a slight weakness in the king's
side
still though this position should be
drawn
instead alexeyenko goes knight queen d7
with the idea of playing for checkmate
here
uh now anish geary for his
horrible reputation that everybody says
this game is sort of
in defense of him he does not play
the safe move a safe move being
something like queen e5
trying to centralize the queen bring it
back to some defensive squares
he plays b6 he says yeah go ahead try to
checkmate me
i want my extra pawn so knight d6
appears on the board
and now queen f6 is defending against
the checkmate
we have queen e8 check king g7 queen d7
king g8 queen e8 check and
now not one to go for repetition
anish giri wants to play for the win so
he plays knight f8
uh and now we have queen c6
queen d8 knight to c4
and okay that entire intro to this
endgame was sort of just
a prelude this i believe is a key
decision point for black
that i now want to talk about up to this
point you know niche gary snatches this
pawn on b2 decides to defend his pawn on
b6
and there's sort of this tactical back
and forth which all of that
is just down to calculation and tactics
which you guys already know to work on
but this is a key decision point and
this is stuff that i think you can
really learn
from these high level players so black
has a decision here
black has an extra pawn on b6
so there are two things that black can
do
black can play knight d7 and try to
defend the pawn
or black can give up the pawn here
so what would you guys do with black
would you play knight d7
try to defend b6 or something else and
if you want to play something else
please enlighten me as to what that
would be
what would it be
mateo says queen d7 chess king says
queen
d3
zayad says he would play knight d7
nikolas wants to try to trade the queens
but he's not sure how
manny says why not try to hold on that
can't be bad it's i mean it's fair
it's an extra pawn why would you give up
an extra pawn
all right someone says knight e6 knight
d7 makes us passive but someone else
wants to play knight d7
the glacier can't seem to find the
initiative
uh yeah and so this is the decision
point here and this is why
i am giving so much credit to anish giri
for this game that he ends up winning
you know i feel like 90
of chess players maybe 99 percent of
chess players would play the move knight
d7
right your pawns attacked defend the
pawn i would play knight d7
why wouldn't you play knight d7 the
issue is that after queen d6
these guys are becoming passive queen a8
check might
uh unpin you can try something like
queen b7 to still hold on to both things
but you're never really breaking free
here right you're just
never really breaking out you can't seem
to find some way to advance your
position and also keep this pawn
defended
if you try queen c6 all of a sudden
you might be losing the game very
difficult now to keep everything
under control so for example
you could play something like queen d5
here you get
checked though and this pawn falls
anyways and so anish realizes maybe
that knight d7 defending this pawn isn't
really the best way to go
and so he finds the right time which is
now to give up this pawn in exchange
for activity so
this is the key decision point that i
want you guys to think about in your own
games
uh yes it is tempting to sort of hold on
to the pawn
but even if you do maintain the pawn and
white doesn't have
this active counter play right away you
sort of need to realize
that b5 and a4 creating a past pawn is
sort of a pipe dream here
because you're never going to be able to
control those two squares well enough
when white has this control over b6
for example i'll even
just pass with with black here i'll just
pass
and and how are you ever achieving the
move b5
i don't know i don't know like white can
even just pass
in this position doesn't need to go for
the craziness just pass
and b5 is never happening no way to make
progress
so anish decides to play the move knight
e6
queen d7 is another great way to give up
the pawn but i like 96 getting the
knight back into the game
alexenko tries to regain the pawn not
with queen b6 which would be met with
takes takes and knight d4 with no
comfortable way to regain this guy if
knight c4
knight b3 defense but knight b6 instead
now knight d4 is gary's idea challenging
these two guys
queen c5 was
uh white's choice which actually does
give the pawn back up
uh white chose this over a move like
queen
b5 because oh well sorry not queen b5
over a move
like is there really no way
to regain to defend this pawn i guess
there's no way to defend this pawn huh
so yeah queen c5
giving up the pawn but the point is
after queen
b5 now white regains the pawn on a5
right this is all making sense again uh
there's no way to sort of deal with both
of these threats now
for black if you try something like
queen d1 to defend the knight
you're just gonna get checked and do
oblivion right gonna get checked forever
and ever and ever
and sorry not queen there but queen e7
and there's no way to get back to
controlling f7
so white regains this pawn but we see
knight d2
queen takes a5 and now
black to move and get an advantage we
have seen anish giri
allow his opponent to liquidate
everything on the queen's side
in return though he has gotten to
activate his own pieces
so yeah some of you guys have the right
idea already
it's to go queen d3 and all of a sudden
it's getting a little bit risky around
this white king
and so this was the the high level stuff
that made me want to go over
this end game from anish giri this
understanding
that even if you can maintain your extra
pawn
it's not going to be enough to win in
order to win
you need to have some type of proactive
plan this goes back to the first end
game we looked at
if you can't come up with a way to make
progress then you're not going to win
the game
regardless of the material count so
instead anish giri plays a little bit
a little bit more freely gives up this b
pawn gives up this a pawn for the b
pawn and goes for uh goes for the throat
with
checkmate now white tries to defend
everything with the move queen to a1
we see queen e4 check the king comes
back to g1
and we see knight f3 check the king
comes to f1
and now uh black
finds a nice tactic knight takes h4
and the point is queen h1 check
threatens to pick up the queen
there's no queen a8 check because the
black queen defends this
and in the words of dmitry komarov
we have made some triangle
and this is a beautiful bit of geometry
that allows anishigiri
to gain a pawn on the king's side and
still fight for the win
uh in the game alexenko goes for queen
a8 check
to try and make the draw we have queen
takes a8
knight takes a8 the knight comes back to
f3
king e2 and knight e5 and
now we have entered a new phase of the
end game we are running a little bit
short on time and i've already gone
over the key point to the end game that
i really wanted to highlight this idea
of giving up
your extra material advantage in
exchange
for some way to actually make tangible
progress
this is something you have to keep in
mind material is nothing
if you can't come up with a proactive
way to make progress
so with all that in mind i'm going to
play through the next moves a little bit
more quickly
this is a really tough end game for
alexeyenko because this knight is so far
away
and the extra pawn is valuable but we do
see
f4 knight g4 knight b6
and we see the black king coming all the
way around now
up and up and up check knight f1 check
some funny business here the knight
comes to g4 we have knight h3
of course if you take king takes g4
these end games are always lost
so knight h3 f6 playing against the
knight
king f3 and the king
circles around
and niche tightens
the grip and eventually comes up with
this nice move
h4 now knight h3 played in the game
king f5 takes king g4
and some clever bit of play
by alex zenko and he was actually
achieving
a drawn position after all believe it or
not
this position is in fact a draw
however he blew it right he fought so
hard all game anish geary put on
so much pressure all game and now the
only thing
that white needed to do to draw was push
this guy
forward and now white or black has no
way to deal with this h pawn
while also playing for the win
f4 check for example king d3
and if we take this guy then white
actually wins
if we try to run back with knight d5 h6
97 h7 knight g6
now it's as simple as queening
and grabbing this guy
and coming back to uh to stop this pawn
it's
that simple now for uh for white
but instead of all that alexandro
stumbles at the final moment doesn't
find the move h5
plays the move knight d3 now all of a
sudden after knight d5
check knight f4 black wins this pawn
outright
and with two extra pawns here it is
enough to win the game
giri pushing all the way home knight d2
check
unstoppable next with king g2 to follow
and it's a victory for anish giri so
really interesting end game it's a shame
we didn't have a little bit more time to
go through
the pure night end game but like i said
the main
thing i wanted to get across is this
idea of
going for a proactive plan to make
progress no matter the cost
we saw it in game one with wong kao
missing the idea of
f4 with this deep idea of preventing the
defensive setup to make progress
and we see it here by anish giri willing
to give up
the queen side extra material in order
to pressure the king
on the king's side and try to make
progress in that manner
if you're watching live the fun is going
to continue on twitch right after this
with analyze your games if you're
watching the youtube
recording this is it for us
thank you so much for joining me here uh
for the end game class as always my name
is caleb denby
and i will see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you